top of the morning to you laddies is
welcome to my crap rejects bed space
Jack's bestest hold on Jack there's
something right there behind you wait
what oh my god don't look is it Enderman
it's an Enderman last episode we built
you may have noticed it's a little
different and that's because maybe
someone accidentally reset the whole map
and we just I didn't do it I don't even
have access to this world know what no
one thinks you should we just like go
and explore our new world see like what
we can hat fine like it's there a
village next door is there like oh I
want to kidnap some people I want to
raid a village
I wanna steal all their stuff I need
potatoes well then we need boats and
potatoes I'm Irish I can't play
minecraft unless I have potatoes my god
what works your health jacket is to plan
to shake your you're losing health Jack
you find potatoes oh we got mushrooms
that's cool and you found them under on
the ground this is a Doric would have
you found this in Minecraft yet I'm not
that far behind have you find these dark
wood oak trees okay that's that's
pumpkins have you found pumpkins yet
yeah I don't know if you found pumpkins
yet yeah I found pumpkins are pretty
dope if we can make a pumpkin farm now
also people are pointing out last
episode you called a chicken a sheep
yeah I don't know how your brain works
but I don't know does it even work I
don't think so
we need dogs yeah let's go find dogs bro
people are so excited for Sven and Sam
to meet oh my god we can we can find
them again in this world it's the same
it's exactly the same those are fake we
should probably just go to sleep again I
just realized
I'm all the way in the deep dark woods
man is going to come and eat me oh god
I'm sleeping all alone I can't fall
asleep without my friend Jack oh God
ouch I can't fall asleep without you
Jack go to sleep
I can't sleep without you Jack can you
can see I went to creative mode to
recreate what we did last episode Oh God
oh the secret the secret is out the lead
Chet wait I keep typing is that you is
that you I hear oh we have a double bed
we have to say no homo before we go to
sleep No
hey it's Pride Week I would go home oh
it's okay homo for your bros okay okay I
eat now because I sleep and I work up
quite appetite your work appetite I do
look at you mr. zombie you dying cause
of fire sunshine that's not cool bruh
sorry I'm just so excited to be playing
Minecraft I've never played this game
before oh my god I found two horsies
wait where what does your horse name my
horses name is Finn bear Finbar and
Jurgen has been found
I like how you immediately already know
that I've named my horse Garth it's a
2014 but you cannot play minecraft with
like naming your voice get out of here
no rarity they're over here tonight
bloody hop in there
oh there's one hanging in the back one
two three yellow the yellow hair yellow
there's yellow it what that's also you
can't have the blonde the one that's the
Swedish here again oh we can babe oh my
god it's okay
let me read you oh that's sad damn I
just realized we can't ride them without
saddles what get off I can get on I just
don't write they don't like me I don't
know why you can't ride them unless you
oh you're on already okay let's go make
saddles can you make sense for a frickin
Minecraft what a freakin - can you make
I'm a micro veteran can you actually
make them or do you have to find them I
think you have to fight realize that I
know he exploded shocker
they never explore creepers explode what
you've never heard of exploding creepers
what if they do the opposite and they
help you build your house you give them
a pickaxe and they're like alright cool
it's just creeper thanks man creeper
thanks brah don't freak out I'm getting
a little sidetracked
okay let me just cook some meat did you
grab all the meat we had like 20 yeah I
did here you want some meat here
starting follow things think I'm stuck
here forever
I'm sorry I'm sorry pumpkin I was like
why so long that's trolling me okay what
we can do is just going to be nighttime
again by the time we actually yeah stop
getting sidetracked okay what we need to
do is we need to make a what your mum up
is is that a swore with lucky to
monetize did you
you know what that word is it knows what
all the other ones are maybe they don't
know
I need torches we have a coal oh we did
yeah somehow magically the Minecraft
gods gave us cold yeah so we have a hole
right it's that's what it's called all
right I didn't actually going was stupid
no that was it that's the level of the
comedy that we're getting here and then
we can plant the wheat right good idea
good idea so we can use the weed to tame
the war the weeds to tame your mom what
my mom see minecraft your mom's and
everyone's minecraft
whoa bro can make your mom in Minecraft
okay that should be the title of an
episode make your mom in Minecraft 10
billion billion views billion views no
one talks about it mr. B's be like what
you can make your mom for ten thousand
dollars in Minecraft that's a title I
[Music]
click on that I made a diamond bomb in
Minecraft
I get nervous parentheses not creative
mode that's the new not click fate of my
yeah okay so we can go back to their
mind and hope that one of the saddles
drops in one of the chests that's in
there in the place that sounds like an
epic plan okay epic plan let's go
where where is hole it's right here oh
you did it I don't have coal you don't
have what I don't have cold so I blind
blind but there's lava wait okay I
thought to make torches all you need two
sticks and coal yeah why can I not make
them have to make you mean the thing
first no you can make them in ten it's
not showing up you can make in the hand
see I'm I'm a dummy dumb I have to use
the little book to build everything oh
dude don't call me out like that all of
us can play seven hours a day of
Minecraft Oh what are you busy doing
I just have five hours no I'm so sorry
bro are you freaking Skelly
oh it makes you don't die oh nice bra
thank you I use axe it's super epic
speed and Irish Viking pull the knife
hey night when colorized I need call oh
there it is
we just hope for Saito's at this point
so we can write it horses ha there's
lava I'm freaking out oh man creeper
I find gold you find gold impossible
growing does not exist in Minecraft
everyone I'm gonna make some gold
sunglasses in Minecraft God you can make
sunglasses they'll be pretty cool yeah
why can't you okay oh heck yeah broski
if I'd like to here I am down I went
down did you have lapis and gold where
are you I went further down great stone
what good we can enchant now already we
can build their pen what am I saying
I don't know okay I find a chest dang it
dang it just sixteen diamonds no so
happy
seriously that's like me when I started
playing I'm like damn it what is this
garbage I $5 hey did you and Golden
Apple hot what we're rich Jack we're
gonna be rich
I almost died in my craft freakin
creeper almost blew me out it was such a
legitimate scream - creeper came up when
I was stuck on the chest oh man oh man
okay I'm so gonna get lost in here okay
so come back - what I'm so deep there
indeed back in the super mega caves oh
okay fine redstone so we can make like a
flashlight wait why do I make these
jokes I would like to not have my videos
that claim demonic Devante host of my
brain very small and I can't small Irish
brain want to swear at everything
I don't know you win I think I heard Oh
perfect I found the villager okay so
coming back bouncing like the big room
that doesn't mean anything I'm back
query we you were saying don't die okay
wait for me I'll be right there
I'm scared me I'm coming looking sticky
spider
don't worry Jackie Keep Calm just keep
calm I'm pretty cam stop freaking out to
stay calm I'm making of a mission I'm
going to be back at the start
dang it this is typically the bow plates
Jack okay perfect oh I'm poisoned I'm
poisoned
I don't like it I'm supposed to stay
there and be called okay I'm coming back
hey I found another golden apples can I
have I could have used that a sec here
just eat go back no I do
I think I'm worthy of it okay okay I
have to find you unkind of losses of all
I'm already back in front of me sir no I
got poison again getting spider sorry
freaking making speaking sorry you make
me smacking I'm looking for you I'm I'm
finding for you come on
thank you health very cool very very
nice why did you disappear
err Jack good I'm I'm so much better at
this in my own game and now here comes
the excuses
dude it was the like I swear ok I'm
going up to the surface and whatever I
find on the surface I will say hey man
this is where I don't miss most is your
sentence if you've ever said no I don't
do well in ok wait for me in bed then I
come okay don't go anywhere I'm sleeping
in bed oh you must be close proximity
chat work next time Jack me go bed
whatever I got the wrong sake it messes
my internal clock ok say this memo for
ya sorry Marzia sorry I'm a a what you
like this but okay we found everything
but a saddle we can grow pumpkins I need
to make iron again cuz I did you do a do
free do P dude I just
i frickin no skin right now I'm gonna
have to default dance on these fools
okay let's go down again well we need to
find more diamond it's my man if we can
make each other a shovel leader that's
pretty cool
that is pretty cool I already have a
shovel though all right see I think
around bed
oh dude you're so smart
dude I've minecraft it a couple of times
now minecraft builders would be like wow
they never thought of that
I'm started weed growing very good oh we
need some bone meal I got some phone
Skelly and it's bone meat by the way is
it bone meat yeah it's well me either
I can't read or people have been lying
to me people be lying all the time dang
let me just double-check if you can't
make a Salem how do you spell Seder
table sa d dl b d le sad boy for life
brah
ok at least have a chest armor look hit
me
no no ah see I can take it full health
again ok it works it works very good
follow me ok let's go follow me but wait
ok I put on boots
ok now I'm good epic soldier time thank
you
those are words that you just said I
like to use words sometimes
oh this is where you were no no I went
down here ok
oh this is where you were not I goes
deep what this is where you uh wait one
sec just give me with sec was it was it
here can I say it yet no it's over yes
wow this is no no not yet I was trying
really hard to find our way out
did you just make diamonds in the chest
yeah ok ok look look look you should do
block oh there's an Enderman right there
oh yeah right that's what I was
screaming epic yet ok let's kill him
let's kill him
no she killed her anyway let's get I'll
do the first hit three two one smile
bias
okay you weren't supposed to bring up
like what bad hold disclosure I Felix's
mom is fine I think this is really yeah
it smells like death no this is not
where I died this is where you were uh I
think there's exploring it's blowing
this cave it's pretty epic in here bro
there's lapis in here
Oh lapis you get lapis brah okay so yeah
this is one of the chests okay what
level are we on are we are we on 12 yet
can we get diamonds Oh bro see now we're
thinking like a true minecraft 1:30
we're freaking 30 dude alright let's go
let's go deeper
let's get diamonds episode 2 yes episode
2 we got diamonds question mark not
creative move oh hey look your nametag
and torches and bread you like bread I
do like bread it's it's almost like a
potato but not really
it's like potato but softer and made
differently hello
I think there's a spider spawn somewhere
yeah
oh it's right there it's fun it's right
I found two spawners it might play
through and destroy both and people got
really mad yeah I did the same and I'm
so mad at myself learn how the game
works oh then you see it again you're
like oh what's wrong with me usually
it's better to just close off areas and
like take it step by step
we're kind of just like diamonds where
are they we're kind of being small brain
right now we're kind of being a little
sporadic it's math okay let's check out
these this for really quick if there's a
chest there's a wicked WANGO down there
there's a wicked WANGO they do happen in
Minecraft oh there's another chest here
name tag whoa okay dude run devil 12 we
can find diamond here okay we keep
digging for ever you go that way I go
this way okay and then after 20 we turn
and then we meet at middle okay turn
okay turn now turn right okay I'm
turning turning
turning can't find you try shed wine
[Laughter]
right I was behind you oh really
all right so we're on floor 28 so we
should still go up I run out of pickaxe
so you're gonna have to dig is it okay
you want you want crappy wooden 100
thanks brah I dig fast yeah get that
iron Brooke when life gets you down and
you hit bedrock just dig up stupid oh I
see you I see your name tag and you're
so far up I'm hitting I'm hitting dirt
Oh daylight that's great jack I'm happy
for you I see your name you're so [ __ ]
up you gave me wood pickaxe and you ran
away from me I ran away from you fair
fair that's that's fair that's a wooden
pickaxe pirate that's me you running
away
that's all you bro I am NOT you're done
what if you were real bro you would look
at my nametag and help me build a little
town this is my no real bro
okay you know what fair again what are
you taking all these shots at me man
because first we sleep together
now this answer oh my god I literally
found exactly her I dog hi we are
brought down okay but now we down
I dig myself but I'm strong independent
man you know actually my pickaxe is
about to die there is light in end of
time I never complain begin see now we
can find our base easily cuz I put
flowers everywhere actually it does have
not gonna lie how have we gone this far
without building a house Jack I don't
try and say a little bit I haven't
accomplished though surprise we're not
dead yet in the game well yeah I don't
have a lot of health um I have some
cobblestone but not a lot what did you
do what did you do with everything you
dug yourself hot with I use it to build
back up again I just wanted to get out I
was being
Oh brain Thank You smaller brain and get
that from my side because you make me
angry
all right so this is as big as we can
get I mean yeah so let's make a big
house big house big house for our big
brains
oh no no no too big what should we name
house oh that's a good a that's a good
question need something European that's
a European place our Chateau is just
French for wrong whatever man I don't
want French people getting mad at me no
no don't cover all don't cover all my
friend I just see hole I see problem in
life and I try pigs okay Jack let me
show you something really everything
doing are you ascending without me oh
you hurt yourself you know I know I'm in
the bed save you I'd save my life we
needed a doorway though where is their
doorway gonna be front middle are you
guys new likes do you like your doorways
in the middle or off set there's a lot
about you where you like your doorway
oh yeah I'm afraid I'm not ready to
answer that question we should make the
housing to monetize simple just so we
get more revenue that's an amazing idea
and I don't know why we didn't think of
it yet I'm making glass okay all right
well go ahead then well I guess we've
just decorated without planning anything
I said it was making the glass I didn't
say I was installing the glass okay our
house looks so cute
this is very pretty put some lilac put
some lavender around it actually ow I'm
gonna be right back just wait for me and
I'm gonna be back I'm gonna build this
entire house myself do you want windows
in these holes or no all holes must be
windows okay so this is gonna be the
envy of every minecrafter notch will be
like okay I buy back minecraft now
why do I sell this game this sounds much
thing this is a Swedish to me speaking
that's not even Swedish this is how
speak okay do your best
Swedish accent not the weird one you do
okay okay what does an actual Swedish
person so hello this is how I talk this
is that's actually not bad
Oh big joke okay okay Irish man I made a
couple friends and I want you to think
about oh yes are you bringing back some
culture to our feeble homes yes okay
what'd I say about friends I take back
and please save my life oh I see you
you're close I can help Swedish help
noises yell you don't even have anything
with you anymore
I lost friends I made peace that's
pretty deep I am half hot I am actually
scared of life sleep fast okay jack
say hi to new friends hello friends
you know you can name one gray sheep and
I'll call him Grayson no wait gray she'd
mind you said I could name one great one
the gray ones mine but I like the gray
ones so much okay gray sheep gets the
same secret chamber okay wait no alright
wait stand back we need to stand next to
each other with wheat in our hand put
away wheat but a way to we all to see
who he comes to
yeah and then whoever he comes to gets
to have him okay okay we in the same
place okay in three two one we changed
to eat okay came to me fine gracious is
water sheep my god
some weird Swedish thing you never told
about no tell me about the little sheep
one of the best people leave now
there you go we have what their sheep is
contained sheep come here go back in
there so much nicer oh this poor little
sheep he's so sad now he loves it he is
the controlling water
do you like it cheap he loves it you get
bath every day rule is forever moist
moist G boys sheep with name tags we
name sheep ok we name him I don't know
her name tag hook I want to try when we
need to make an animal they're quite
expensive need lots of iron yeah we have
25 ok how do you make an iron block it's
like it's a full thing of iron anyone
more oh no problem man here you take Oh
alright there it is what do we name him
whatever your heart so desires what do
you feel like name me feel like to you
what there she is back I think he wants
door what does she want door yeah here
you go
special sheep ok
today new day we go explore north is
that north I don't know where North is I
don't have complex or map ok West we go
west this way just say back of house ok
we should ask water sheep let water
shoes joint which direction we should go
which way it should we go watershed we
have to give them sacrifice get the baby
lamb we have to sacrifice the baby get
the baby get the baby baby come here we
bravely you second sacrifice for water
brother all right
ok we brought you sacrifice now fellas
hey look at this way he looked that way
and up we have to go to the sky ok but
if there was a sky realm there called
sky means we watched so far in the wrong
direction dude were so far away
there's the mushroom
Oh God Oh
[Music]
I ran out of food against freight
but it's your ass pray to water sheep or
what they're sheep please give us a
drink
did we really just go in the complete
wrong direction from the very beginning
I think there's a tiny baby after me and
I'm too scared to look back oh god you
have tiny baby after you as well
f5 bro oh god oh god oh god honey baby
that damn is it tiny villager we should
actually cure it by cure it do you mean
kill it yeah how do you know oh he got
blocked by cow
Thanks don't go to the trees throw the
trees jack wood there's the only way
this is the most anticlimactic chase
this is the most epic chase of Naruto
what if we find giant the meatball yeah
I'm there too where you go hey I'm right
here so I actually didn't mean thing I
didn't friendship hurts friendship it's
over that was Cupid we made it to the
ocean I said you mean the ocean Oh yawn
Yoshi Yoshi that's a foul you have to
put it at the start okay guys next week
we will find treasure the next episode
still guaranteed - like for more
Scandinavian Irish adventures smash like
if you really like this accent bah what
you never played - / simile
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]